right so
thanksgiving is next thursday have you
started shopping for the big meal
many of you have because the store
shelves are already empty in some places
but if you haven't you may actually want
to get started today the prices are
rising bianca holman joining us live in
eight news now kitchen with where you
can find those good deals bianca
hey good morning john good morning
heather so hopefully you have stocked up
your fridge and you're ready to roast
that turkey because things are flying
off the shelves at the supermarket so we
of course looked up some deals for you
and we actually looked up at this
website it is called pennypinchers.com
and they share some great savings that
you might want to take advantage of to
save some coins so the goal is to snag
your coupons and find the deals early
but this year the nation's supply chain
crunch is making some items harder to
find and one thing you may have already
noticed turkeys the u.s department of
agriculture says inventory is down 24
percent this year
on the website penny pinchers they list
target as having butterball turkeys for
99 cents per pound but stores like
walmart are charging a dollar 48 uh per
pound also albertsons and sprouts
they're charging almost two bucks per
pound uh for those turkeys and of course
on our website uh on social media and
twitter we have reached out and saying
hey what do you plan on doing have you
bought your turkeys already so there's a
couple of people that posted they said
they may have gotten theirs from
albertsons and then also there's some
people who want to do prepared meals
they don't plan on getting in the
kitchen and banging pots and pans around
they said they're doing lucille's
barbecue
for thanksgiving dinner so coming up in
the next half hour we're going to talk
about more tips and ways that you can
save this holiday season back to you
guys next time
the barbecue yeah buy it all there's so
many good places to do that here in las
vegas no reason to stress out about it
thank you very much